Now let's discuss the primitives that are available
in the coral for manipulating the floppy DHT
in particular the put and get operation. The
primitives are exactly the same, it's just that the
semantics of the put and get are very
different in terms of how it is actually implemented.
So put takes on two parameters Key and
value. Key is the content hash, and value is
the node ID of the proxy with the content for the particular key.
Essentially, this put is announcing the willingness of
the proxy to serve the content whose signature is key. The
put can be initiated by the origin server with the new content,
or it could also be initiated by a node that
just downloaded the content and wants to serve as a proxy to reduce the load of
the origin server. In both cases they will
want to do a put operation. And the result
of doing the put operation is to store
this key value, in some metadata server. That is
some node that is going to serve as a
name server that can, answer queries coming in saying,
I am looking for this key. In that
case, that metadata server can return the value,
associated with that key. So what we need to do when we do a put operation, is
to place this key value in an appropriate
node. Now, what do we mean by an appropriate
node? Ideally, what we want to do is, given a key, we want to store it in a node
ID whose ID is N equal to key. That's the desired node
where we want to place it, but we want to do this without
really causing a metadata server overload. Now
how do we determine if a particular node is overloaded?
Well, what we're going to do is define two states.
One state is called a full state, and what that is saying is a particular node,
let's say node n, is already storing l values for a key. Remember what I said
earlier, this key value pair can be placed
by either the origin server that is creating
the content. Or it could be placed by a proxy who is saying, I'm willing to
serve as a proxy for the content. So there could be lots of nodes that
have the content, and are willing to serve the content. All of them would have
done put operations. So the node that
matches exactly the key. That, is being put.
They already have quite a few candidates, that
are willing to serve as the content providers
for that particular key. That's this parameter
full that's saying, I'm willing to host up
to L entries, for this key value pair. Anything more than that, I'm not going
to do that. I'll get overloaded. So the full is a condition, you could say
it's a special condition that's saying, I'm willing
to entertain up to l content providers for
a particular key k. The second way a particular node may get overloaded is,
if it actually starts getting a large number of requests for a particular key.
So, this is a time metric that says a node has a beta parameter, and the
beta parameter is the number of requests per unit time. That a
node is entertaining. So if it says that I'm
already entertaining beta requests for this particular key and
therefore, if you want me to store the same
key, I'm going to say no, I cannot do
it because I'll get overloaded. So this is a
space metric that's saying, how many values I'm willing
to store for a particular key. Loaded is stating
how many requests per unit time I'm willing to entertain
for a particular key. Those are the two metrics we're going to use in
determining whether to place a key value pair at a particular destination node.